es posible que ustedes ya estén
familiarizados con la noción de evaluar
una función con un valor particular por
ejemplo si tenemos esta definición de
función y decimos cuál es el valor de f
de menos 9 si vemos que la entrada es
menos 9 en nuestra definición de función
vemos que le corresponde un 5 por lo que
f de menos 9 es igual a 5 y quizá
también estén familiarizados con las
funciones compuestas por ejemplo tenemos
efe de f de menos 9 más 1 esto es
interesante y aunque se ve algo difícil
realmente no lo es tanto ya que sabemos
cuánto es
efe de menos 9 esto de aquí es 5 así que
esto es f de 5 más o no que es igual a
efe de 6 y si vemos la tabla tenemos que
es igual a menos 7 todo esto es sólo una
revisión lo que quiero hacer ahora es
evaluar el inverso de una función y esta
función
efe
puede invertirse ya que es un mapeo o
una relación uno a uno entre las equis y
las f x ninguna de las equis mapean al
mismo valor de fx así que es una función
que podemos invertir con esto en mente
veamos si podemos invertir algo como efe
- 1 o efe inversa de 8 a que será igual
esto los invito a que pausa en el vídeo
y traten de pensar en ello recordemos lo
que hacen las funciones
fx va a relacionar un valor en su
dominio
hacia su respectivo valor en el rango
eso es lo que hace efe
este es mi dominio y este es mi rango el
inverso de f va a tomar un valor en el
rango y lo va a relacionar a mapear de
vuelta con su valor en el dominio y esto
es lo que hace efe - 1 pues cómo
resolvemos efe inversa de 8 esta es la
función inversa
efe a la menos uno bueno como resolvemos
la función inversa de 8 este 8 es el
valor que está en el rango y éste es el
8 y que es lo que relacionó al 8 en la
tabla vemos que efe de 9 es 8 por lo que
la f inversa de 8 va a ser 9
así que esto es igual a 9 para hacerlo
más fácil construyamos una tabla aquí y
de hecho esto me va a servir para
asegurarme de no hacer cosas raras x
efe inversa de x y lo que voy a hacer es
intercambiar estas columnas por ejemplo
si fx va de menos 9 a 5
efe inversa de x irá de 5 a menos 9 lo
único que hice fue intercambiar estos
valores para ahora relacionar esto con
esto el siguiente es 7 a menos 7 en
lugar de relacionar este menos 7 con el
7 vamos a mapear esto con esto el
siguiente va de 13 a 5
luego de menos 7 a 6 después va de 8 al
y finalmente de 12 a 11
vamos a revisar y parece que no me falta
nada la función inversa mapea o
relaciona esta columna con esta otra
columna de la izquierda ahora podemos
ver más claramente que si ponemos 8 en f
inversa de x vamos a obtener 9 con esto
podemos comenzar a hacer cosas más
sofisticadas podemos evaluar algo como f
de f inversa de 7 bueno primero
evaluamos
efe inversa de 7 esto relaciona 7 con
menos 7 por lo que esto de aquí dentro
va a ser igual a efe de menos 7 y si
evaluamos la función vemos que relaciona
menos 7 con siete de nuevo esto es igual
a 7 lo cual tiene perfecto sentido es la
inversa de 7 fue de 7 a menos 7 y al
evaluar esto en la función regresamos al
7 hagamos otro ejercicio más para
terminar de familiarizarnos con esto de
mapear o relacionar esto de ida
y vuelta entre dos conjuntos aplicando
la función y el inverso de la función o
función inversa evaluamos
efe inversa de f inversa de 3
a que será igual los invito a que pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo por
su cuenta cuál es la función inversa de
13 vemos la tabla y aquí vemos que va de
13 a 5
vemos de este otro lado que pasamos de 5
a 13 por lo que el inverso irá de 13 a 5
por lo que nos queda efe inversa de 5
cuales vemos que de 5 pasamos a menos 9
esto es igual a menos 9 nuevamente el
inverso de 5 si la función es de menos 9
a 5 el inverso de la función irá de 5 a
menos 9 al principio cuando vemos una
función y el inverso de esa función pues
nos puede parecer algo confuso pero solo
deben recordar que una función en
relación a un conjunto de números con
otro conjunto de números y el inverso de
esa función o su función inversa va en
el sentido contrario si la función va de
9 a 8 la función inversa irá de 89 por
lo que sólo tendríamos que intercambiar
estas columnas espero que esto les haya
aclarado el concepto y no los haya
confundido más